hi I'm Ryan right I'm Noel quit so I'm
Dante has released the official trailer
of the roast of Ryan right
featuring the dude from honest trailers
okay let me take out my glasses for this
people have been asking me to post my
reaction for the five creepiest 9-1-1
calls I want to say right now I know I
have a certain reputation stuff I am NOT
gonna post my reaction to that video I
know most of you subscribers have seen
it already so it won't be a big deal if
I if you're I'm just showing my reaction
to it but I don't want to be the one who
introduces that video to anyone I don't
think that video is entertaining I know
some people gonna be surprised on saying
this but I think it's kind of insulting
to the people who were related to these
victims yeah it's and I don't want to
post a video for entertainment purposes
off of the deaths of five people it's
disrespectful to the families in my
opinion if I posted it I wanted to
monetize the video and I don't want to
generate viewership for it I don't want
to generate subscribers for it I want
people to come here for fun positive
[ __ ] not because I'm reacting to like
these horrible traumatic things you know
yeah I'm just not okay with that I know
other people did it I know time around
posted his reaction totally fine by me I
don't care what anyone else does I
really know but for me personally that's
why I won't do it now I'm Dante let's
see if you can get me to break in a time
when all that reactors did was react
came a man who had more in mind
with this YouTube channel on its catchy
name I'm Dante wait I'm Dante really
Mogae he decided that he would do a
roast on the biggest reactors out there
because well he had nothing else better
to do and thus the roast of Tyrone
Magnus was born and it was spread around
like wildfire everybody took the roast
well and he couldn't have been happier
like I knew this was going to happen to
like us as reactors you know I mean I
didn't expected to come from a reactor
it's not first time saying on his videos
- yeah - - that's pretty funny were you
I did I didn't expect to enjoy [ __ ]
good this is really good this man to
show this to meet challenge what you've
got my little ninja turtle that was that
was pretty funny and I hopefully when
you become bigger in the reactor
universe and the reactor burst we can
collaborate in the future and mine you
know I can make sure I show you just how
saga Stein has an ego this Hawkeye
really an alliance to get to me
then his life got twisted turned upside
down right rights are the roast and he
just frowned not only was Ryan's
reaction to the roast unbearable to
watch he also insulted Dante to tears
leaving him to cower in the corner like
an infant jeez Ryan I thought that from
over here while the roast of Tyrone
rides the waves of success there have
been others trying to ride the wave as
well wait a second why did it cut to me
I see how it is real original movie man
Marc copied on Dante uh know what if I
were to tell you that I came up with the
idea to do it roasted the south Oh Bros
way before Dante uploaded his roast for
Tyrone Magnus then I'd be lying
bad roulette who was too blind to see
that all the jokes here over complete
garbage crotch out one clockwork cyborg
who in all honesty should stick to
trolling because he trolled Tyrone into
thinking he would be funny I've been
watching clockwork cyborg for a while
matter fact I haven't watched you in the
wild man ain't I remember my first time
out literally and a couple of days went
through all your videos I was piss on a
penis laughing it is cold and many
others that nobody cares about
now with thousands of subscribers behind
him and all of them practically begging
for a second roast he's proud to say
that it has been completed
Haru hosted by I'm Dante and storing
aqus on the night sup dubrow's tyrone
magnus mama jumbo and finally the real
rejects I feel like when he does another
roast he's gonna go I don't care if you
go don't go brew it on anyone but you
better go as [ __ ] hard as you can
like really [ __ ] brutal rows of Ryan
right let's watch Tyrone's reaction
he's so cool I mean I talk sometimes he
likes your tongue it likes that wide
open mouth long tongue well Manny told
me that what a [ __ ] I always got be
[ __ ] all the women in my videos why
can't I be a nice guy why can't I just
be a nice man that's making reaction
videos with attractive ladies why can't
I be like Ryan right oh girl your hands
okay they're only here for views they
probably got to see it right now here is
six dos be going to sex clubs
well orgies with your big black [ __ ]
yeah I don't smell your ass while you're
doing it I can see it happening I could
just see I just know they were nice tie
room oh let's check out the roof of Ryan
right official trailer let's get it on
we're doing something whole time yes
semi actors did was react came a man
read more in mind
first I thought it hurt himself we did
the kid we're gonna mess around with
this YouTube channel it's a magic name
on Dante wait I'm Dante really okay he
decided that he would do a roast on the
biggest reactors out there because well
he had nothing else better to do is
[ __ ] cool man you got them to do this
for you this is [ __ ] crazy man that's
pretty cool I gotta give him kudos that
was born and it was spread around like
wildfire everybody took the roast well
and he couldn't have been happier yeah
reactors
Jonte I watched you know I have a
comeback ready I'm working on it right
now September 15 what you do hopefully
you're not gonna be ready for what I got
I'm big but I got a child
so buddy yes like this then it's like
that twisted turned upside down right
rights of the roast and he just round
not only was Ryan's reaction to the
roast unbearable to watch
he also insulted Dante to tears leaving
him to cower in the corner like an
infant jeez Ryan whenever got me
attention while the roast of Tyrone
rides the waves of success
beragon others trying to ride the
bedroom leg it was to see all the crotch
i won yeah yeah he's got a crotch
outline
buddy smiles that's two days after my
birthday honest trailers man you gotta
write me or tell me in the video how you
got them a that's [ __ ] cool [ __ ] but
it's like bad holes and everywhere I
fought the lot
Oh Alan's saying holes all your comments
down below absolutely love the video if
you enjoyed my reaction
it's like button subscribe and share if
you did not it's a like button subscribe
and share 1 million subscribers 1
million no his whole thing is he's
trying to get into a million subscribers
okay alright I kept my poker face on in
case I was roasted I want my comebacks
to be a surprise you know if I'm here
hollering and laughing like Tyrone when
they're talking about how they're gonna
roast me mm-hmm
no man I'm gonna be ready for you I
won't be posting my reaction to your
video on September 5th I'm actually
performing music live on September 5th
at event called color my energy so yeah
I bet you guys didn't know I do music
but I see that more than just the
reactor alright guys well thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you could check out
Noelle's channel I mean why not she is
dirty blonde she's a dirty blonde and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter I have a vine and up periscope e
so yeah let's woman I am talking man
speaking hold on